what is your perfect gaming experience
connor what is your perfect game
no the [ __ ] off no league player would
ever say that oh well why do you play so
much
well that's a good question joey
addiction there should be a systems in
place
there's some restrictions on how
don't try to tell me league addiction is
not a thing it is a [ __ ] thing
yeah yeah but it's not like you i mean
it's you have to try very hard to ruin
your life with a league addiction
you have to really be on that path um
but
i don't know perfect game for me i don't
know maybe like something like one of
the halo games it was a very [ __ ]
good game perfect game experience you
get a good game maybe some wait some of
them had like dlc but that's
points down for that points down for
that yeah i don't know
are you talking about like og halo yeah
yeah like hello one two
hello one or two really [ __ ] good
games just a game that has an experience
that is when it's over
what about like a current game a current
game was hades is probably the best game
i've played recently
all right that's a fantastic example of
a game no dlc no [ __ ]
you should play the game you know you
get the story if you want that
i'm not into that yeah that ain't me i
mean by the gameplay
[ __ ] amazing to me to me to me like i
90
of the games i ever play i don't finish
i i i
don't know why i can weak mindset no no
exactly like i get to a point
no i'm i'm just you come during sex so
you just walk out halfway through come
on
does the sex does the sex
i don't play final fantasy i don't i
don't play yakuza i don't play any of
those long games right at all so that's
longest game i played was like [ __ ]
blue dragon or something [ __ ]
like i have to be like properly invested
in this stuff and i'm the type of guy
who
you know i get really into a game and
then i hit about like the 20 hour mark
and then i still have a quarter of the
story left or a quarter of the gameplay
left
and i i feel like i've gotten everything
out of that game that i need to do
and then i just stop playing you know
what i mean like part of a lot
a big reason why i you know even with
gacha games is that if there's not
that reason for me to keep playing or if
there's not that if i'm not getting
something new out of it
then i just drop it what do you mean
it's just a [ __ ] daily quest every
day that's what i mean well sometimes i
like the story sometimes i
you know sometimes it is you know
sometimes i'm sometimes
you want to get that grind for that
character the moment you said story he
just checked out
he's i could see his brain just blowing
power down i kind of father my people
want to grind like
why people put themselves through that
it's it's torture i mean it's
it's kind of like just that mindless
task right yeah it's just
something to do you feel like you're
accomplished or something [ __ ] are you
telling me that
league isn't a grind after a point it's
a [ __ ] grind it's just
it's just a grind with more complicated
controls
you know what i mean yes it is yes
there's a loss and there's a
like a win and a loss have different
outcomes grinds there's only one outcome
you just win you just you do the thing
that you're meant to do and then you've
already
depends how you grind yeah but it's like
all right i've got my spreadsheet out
it's going to take eight years of
grinding of killing these balls what
what is what what is that how you do
every jrpg player we have a [ __ ]
spreadsheet no but
in your mind it's like i'm going to do
this mindless task five times to get
this
what is the end goal of league there is
no end goal it's like self-improvement
in mechanics
exactly checkmate so that's exactly it
right because that's my problem with
competitive games i
you know you i every time i get to do a
competitive game whether it be league
overwatch um [ __ ] valent or whatever
is like the the
golden period is the first time when
you're learning the game right and you
start getting good at the game anything
you start learning the systems and then
you start the ranks you start the ranks
playing you start climbing that's when
the game is
fun when you feel like what you've
learned has had a tangible effect right
but everyone everyone will hit that wall
everyone will hit that wall where you
climb as hard as you can
unless you're [ __ ] faker or something
what you've i mean you've won like the
world tournament that's because that's
that is basically the only end goal
there can be in any competitive game to
be the best in the world right
yeah and so everyone will reach a point
where it becomes a grind
because there's there's no way that you
can overcome that wall
without grinding your way to overcome
that wall yeah and then
and then that's a self-improvement and
then you reach and then after you do
that
you reach another wall and then another
wall after that but it's constantly like
improving a skill but in like jrpgs and
you know gadget games often
it requires no skill to do the grinding
in fact it requires the opposite
but what i'm saying is you feel like
you're because the whole you're
working towards a goal you're like you
talk about self-improvement well you're
working towards the goal you're you're
gaining something to us gacha games is
just that i mean like
we've we've not just gotcha games but
like i'm pretty sure like any mmo right
when you're grinding
you just feel like you're making
progress towards something you just
you're just less
that's like fun to people just like
having the thing like the super easy
thing just play out you're like not
engaged at all just because you're going
towards something yeah you know
sometimes i don't want to feel shitty
when i've you know played five league
games and lost five in a row and i'm
just like i play games to have fun not
to engage
it's it's it's just like you're just
activating like the [ __ ] neurons you
don't need to worry about it i just like
being lost i just like being challenged
constantly like i want something that
like is challenging you
always like and the moment you grind how
do you not get tired
what do you mean i don't know why i like
being challenged constantly do you not
feel like competitive games get to get
to right get get to a grind after a
point do you not feel like
you get to a point where i feel like
okay i genuinely think unless i put x
amount of effort in i'm not gonna
improve at this game yeah right
i normally just quit at that point
because i'm like all right i feel like
i've gotten
all the challenge i can out of this game
in a reasonable amount of time right i'm
gonna find something else
yeah and that's exactly the same for me
when i when it reached the point where i
reached that grind half of these gadget
games have auto play
so what are you doing sorry what are you
doing
yeah i mean that's that's why that's why
you know what
the only times i'm okay with autoplay is
when it's on a mobile
because i'm [ __ ] staring at my phone
while it's auto playing the entire time
i'm doing other [ __ ]
yeah yeah but because i've been out with
you and you're auto playing on the thing
and you've got to like keep track of it
a little bit make sure it's all going
well you're like okay
for like two seconds and then we're
doing other things you also can't use
your phone in that time because you're
doing the mission so you can't reply i'm
sorry i have other things to do then
look at my phone
i have i have emails to reply to joey i
have you know messages i got to reply
to you man you know it's busy life but
you know yeah i don't know
i also i also like not [ __ ] my
battery which is like really annoying on
the gacha games
when i was playing arc nights my i had
to carry a [ __ ] spare charger with me
everywhere
my battery was [ __ ] dying for me when
gadget games stopped getting fun
is the moment i start thinking about
optimization because when i start
thinking about optimization i'm just
like okay now
now i'm just now that i'm just like that
that is the challenge for me in galaxy
which because once i figure out how i
can optimize this game maximized
right then it's not fun but i figured
that out immediately because all the
shit's online and everyone tells you how
to do it
so once you've you've seen this yeah so
you basically like just willingly is
like i just figured
out a way to make this game not well
there is nothing about what are you
auto playing [ __ ] [ __ ] when you're
opening up a spreadsheet
and you know [ __ ] actually thinking
about how to optimize this and optimize
that that's when it stops getting fun i
just like the experience
of just doing like a very like a very
simple activity i don't need to worry
about it and i just feel like i'm
gaining something and it's it's not i'm
not going to say that hey this is the
peak of all
entertainment this is why i play video i
guess you know what i mean it's just a
nice little thing i
cannot understand like my brain cannot
wrap around the thought of just
just progressing maybe i'm the monkey
brain in this thing because to me the
idea of progressing
to a goal without actually doing
anything seems like the dumbest thing
ever
like how is it a goal if you're not
progressing because
[ __ ] life is stressful enough bro
like what do you mean it's like
i get rid of life is already a challenge
we don't i don't want another challenge
on the side yeah i
de-stress by getting like challenged to
do stuff
outside of like you're [ __ ] weird
because there's no pressure if i lose in
a ranked game i'll give a [ __ ] it's
my i'm not going to get my [ __ ]
mortgage taken away from me like
it's nothing like that right with a
mindset like that i'm surprised you're
not a speed runner
no no because that's the exact same
mentality i feel no no no that's
psychotic
because that's like i want the same
experience again with a minute
difference
that that to me like blows my mind like
that's exactly what i'm hearing right
now no no
because when i get done with the
challenge i'm done i'm on with another
game right like
these speedrunners will spend like two
months to get a one-second optimization
right and i'm like that's what are you
all about optimization yeah and other
things but not my like complete my fun
like my fun is learning something and
getting better at it like
i will optimize i mean i mean when you
say that that is speed runners because
they're learning a game yeah
optimizing almost an obsessive amount
though i think
like i get it this because i've i got
into like speed running like carpet at
one point right
that was quite fun because i was seeing
good improvements yeah but the moment it
became
not fun is when i would do a 40-minute
run and i i was just like
i don't really know what to do now i
didn't really see much to improve and
then i would look online and i'd be like
okay i guess i can i can do this but
yeah sure the mechanical aspect of
trying to get better at like a certain
thing was better but it was a challenge
yeah but it was it was it was not when
you play against other players there is
an always and constant direct challenge
facing you and every second there is
constant
decisions you have to make to outplay
and every new game is a new experience
yeah right there's a lot of things that
are the same but with a speedrun i think
the problem i have with it
is that it's always like we follow the
formula and then we try and improve on
the formula
little by little right which is not kind
of fun because if you're doing like
people do like three hour games at speed
runs it's like
they might do like a two second
optimization here
and then redo everything the same way
right that sounds like insanity to me
you're not changing anything there's no
variation you're just changing one
detail constantly trying to improve it
and sure i can understand why that's fun
to someone
but for me i can't do that and i i just
can't get invested in that that's just
not what i do
so what do you get invested in then like
again like i said self-improvement
self-improvement and the fact what is
your definition of fun my life
what is fun what is fun it's a skill
right and then
seeing how well i can apply the skill on
the fly to things like how well i can
learn it and adapt to situations
is what's fun to me i like losing
because that means i can get better
for me i play video games because i just
like escapism you know you know
that that is my escapism yeah to me
video games i like i do this
i do that enough in my real life you
know what i mean if if
probably that's probably why i [ __ ]
watch so many easter car rounds i'm just
i'm just realizing this now man
but no like i came to another world but
yeah it's it's just like
i want to do something where you know
sometimes with the arch games you know
there's no way you could lose at a gas
game unless you're [ __ ] spending
money but like
like in terms of like the grindy and the
progress there's no way to lose against
it
so you just don't like losing you don't
like losing who does like losing
i like losing you're [ __ ] the
experience no it's not
every fighting game player is obsessed
with losing i swear yeah that's why
they're all psychotic that's like some
[ __ ] martial arts mantra
oh yes